hi there i haven't done a video in quite
a while and uh i'm going away on a trip
so i thought i would do one
i don't know if i'll be able to do any
while i'm traveling in europe
i'm going to be in france on the wood
business and then in germany at a
language conference and in portugal
where i will be giving some
lectures if you want together with the
university of mineo language center
talking about language learning
uh what i say in the age of the ipad
uh but i want to talk today about
something that i think is very important
in language learning but i think it's
the key the key measure
of uh how we're doing when we're
learning a language
and the key goal that i always have in
learning a language
and that is
words
you know if i'm looking for a
um
gordian knot
measure of how well we know a language i
like the idea that it's the number of
words we know
now this will usually get all the
linguistics people saying well what do
you mean by knowing a word
you know
and yes there are degrees of knowing a
word you begin by having a bit of a
sense of the meaning and the more you
see the word in different context the
better you know it
and you eventually get to know which
words are similar and how it's different
from
um
other synonyms and you get better at it
but to me it's just enough to be able to
make
sense of a word when you see it in a
context that's enough you now know the
word and the more words you know
the more you can read the more you can
make sense of things that you are
reading and listening to even if your
understanding of that word is a little
imprecise it doesn't really matter
because you're then able to kind of
guess at
the broader meeting meaning of more and
more content and as you can expose
yourself to more and more content
you learn more words because the more
words you know the more you can infer
the meaning of the other words the more
words you pick up incidentally
the more you learn about the culture of
the language
hopefully
the more you are exposed to the
different patterns of the language
so that
really it's it's it's the more words you
have the more words you can learn the
more you can learn about the language
and so uh at link our one of our major
measuring sticks is how many words you
know
now people get all excited about well
dude i don't i don't really know them
and i don't want to give myself credit
for knowing them to my mind none of that
matters
it's just a measurement that shows that
you are progressing in the language
and in my own case with russian i i
certainly haven't flash carded all the
words that i have saved
at link but i now
can read most of what i'm you know i
understand most of what's there there
aren't that many words that i don't know
so
the number of words you know that to me
is the gordian knot
and you can test it with a closed test
let's say with a very high pass fail so
that you could test people to see how
many words
they know
typically if these words have been
acquired
on what i call honestly through a lot of
listening and reading not
crammed from some word list
then it implies that the person has put
themselves through a process of of uh
of a lot of input reading and listening
and if you have been
heavily oriented towards reading and
listening but you have been building up
your vocabulary
when you have a chance to speak you'll
very quickly improve in your speaking
obviously if you have a chance to speak
earlier so much the better
but
if for a long time as is the case with
my russian it's mostly input
i'm quite confident that as i have more
opportunity to speak
i will improve my speaking but i will
have lots of words and slowly i will
convert these passive words into active
words because i'll be involved in
speaking with someone and they're using
words which i understand and i'm looking
for vocabulary which i know i have
somewhere but i can't yet use and so
each of these engagements so to speak
engagements with the enemy
language confrontations
uh challenges me reminds me of what's
missing and and helps me to go into my
treasure trove of passive words and
gradually convert them to active
so
to me
the big thing what i strive for the
milestones in my language learning my
number one task is to accumulate words
uh
yeah some people say well you know it's
always best to take the first 100 and
the next 100 and and certainly it is
easier to deal with content that has
fewer
new words and i
will come across a word that i need only
to get through a particular
article and i know i won't remember that
word because i won't see it again for
six months and that's fine too and when
i see it again six months later i'll
look it up again and and it'll take a
longer time
to click in
but
again i think
we can learn these words again largely
through a lot of input
uh
and initially dealing with simpler
content
in order to increase the frequency of
these uh
you know more basic words that you have
to learn but there you have it i just
thought i'd mention that i i just think
it comes up all the time it's crucial to
our program at link it's the number one
goal
if if you do that everything else will
fall into place you will
get used to the grammatical structures
you will develop the ability to speak
not to say that you needn't occasionally
review the grammar of course you do and
that's not to say that you needn't go
out and speak when you have an
opportunity of course you should
but if you have the words that gives you
the strongest possible foundation in
order to become better and more accurate
in your use of the language in other
words in the grammar and also to become
a more proficient speaker so in learning
languages focus on words that's at least
my take on it thank you for listening